when I talk to people about doing the
future authoring program they often put
it off and it's not surprising because
it's hard and and but it's more than
that they think well I don't know how to
write I'm gonna do a bad job I don't
really like assignments I'm going to
have to do it perfectly I need to wait
till I have enough time and like one of
those is enough to stop you cold and all
five of them you're just done and so I
tell people do it haphazardly a tiny bit
at a time and badly because you can do
that I tell my students when they're
doing their thesis master's thesis write
a really bad first draft and then we
have a little conversation about that
because they don't think I mean that
because it sounds like a cliche in some
sense it's not a cliche it's not a
cliche at all it means you're a terrible
writer but but if someone put a gun to
your head and said you have to have your
hundred page thesis done by next Monday
or I'll shoot you but I don't care how
terrible it is you would sit down and
write it and the thing is then you have
it right then then you have something
and then you can fix it you can iterate
and fix it that bad first draft that's
the most valuable thing and so that's
what you need you need a bad first draft
of yourself and there's there's an idea
that young developed about the trickster
and the Jester the comedian right that
the trickster is the precursor to the
savior that's one of the things I
learned from young it was just it's so
unlikely you'd never think that it's so
amazing that that might be the case but
the the the the satirical in the ironic
and the troublemaker that the comedian
the fool the fool is the precursor to
the savior why because you're a fool
when you start something new and so if
you're not willing to be a fool then
you'll never start anything new and if
you never start anything new that you
won't develop and so the willingness to
be a fool is the precursor to
transformation and that's the same as
humility and so if you're gonna write
your destiny you can do a bad first job
you're gonna get smarter as you move
forward that's the thing is that so
something beckons to you that's what
happens here maybe the star that
Geppetto wished on was the wrong damn
star
but at least it was a star right at
least it was in the sky at least it
moved him forward and so you say in your
life well something grips you and and
and fills you with interest and you
think well should I do that and the
answer is if not that then something
what if it's a mistake it's a mistake
rest assured what do you know you're
gonna stumble around right and what's
gonna happen is this you're gonna move
to you're gonna not stay in stasis
you're not gonna wander around in
circles and I see people like that they
said well I never knew what to do and
now I'm 40 it's like that's not so good
that's not so good and you might say
well and there is a literature too that
suggests that people are a lot more
unhappy when they look back in their
lives about the things they didn't do
than they are about the mistakes they
made while they were doing things and so
that's really worth thinking about too
because there's redemptive mistakes and
a redemptive mistake would be a mistake
that you make when you go out and try to
do something and no you actually you
think okay I'm gonna try to do this and
you're not good at it you make a bunch
of mistakes it's like what's the
consequence if you pay attention is
you're not quite so stupid anymore
that's the thing is you've been informed
by your by the results of your errors
and so what happens is you you you
follow the beacon you follow the light
and and you're blind so you don't know
where the light is it's it's dimly
apprehended only and you're afraid to
follow it but you decide to take some
stumbling steps towards it and as you
take stumbling steps towards it you
become illuminated and enlightened and
informed because of the nature of your
experience because you're pushing
yourself beyond where you are and you're
going into the country that you have not
yet been in and you learn something and
so what happens then is the star moves
you move ten feet towards it you think
no that's not right I didn't get it
right it isn't there it's actually there
and so then you you see it somewhere
else and you shift yourself slightly and
you move forward and that's what happens
is that you continue as you change the
thing that guides you forward moves
right it's like God in the in the in the
desert in Egypt the pillar of light
you're following it's moving it's not a
permanent thing you move towards it it
moves away it guides you forward and so
you say well is what I'm aiming at
paradise itself and the answer to that
is no because what do you know you could
you couldn't see paradise if it was
right in front of you but you might get
a glimmer of it and so you move towards
it and you grow and then the next time
you open your eyes you see a little bit
more clearly and that's what happens is
that just happens over and over right it
keeps moving and so you move like this
but the thing that's so cool is that
all those zigs and zags you say in each
of those zags is and zigs is a
catastrophe
I hit a wall my god and then I had to
die a little bit and I barely got back
up it's a Phoenix transformation at each
at each turn and it's painful but the
thing is is that even though you've
you've traveled 20 miles let's say on
that road and you've only moved 3 miles
forward you've moved three miles forward
instead of falling backwards because
that's the thing too is that if you
stand still you fall backwards you
cannot stand still because the world
moves away from you if you stand still
and there's no stasis there's only
backwards and so if you're not moving
fact we're back forwards then you're
moving backwards and that's more more of
the underlying truth of the Matthieu
principle to those who have everything
more will be given from those who have
nothing everything will be taken it's a
warning do not stay in one place well as
you zigzag maybe then maybe the
cataclysm of each transformation starts
to lessen there's not so much of you
that has to die with every mistake and
maybe you end up oriented at least
reasonably properly and if you were
sensible that would have been your trip
but it wasn't right it's that and
perhaps it's a lot worse than that
perhaps there's no shortage of
backtracking but it doesn't matter
because as you stumble forward you you
illuminate and inform yourself and
perhaps that's partly because
the world is made of information and if
you encounter it and tangle with it then
it informs you and then you become
informed and then you're in formation
and then you're ready